and now he's the prime minister center
but that's the man we need for the
moment you know we've won hopefully the
war of the pandemic now we've got to win
the peace and re-energize the country
and get everybody back into work again
when he was mayor when you were working
for him of course he used to talk up
london and london's contribution he's
now we understand going to talk about
the southeast being overheated how do
you feel about that well i think the
point is that we've got to look after
the whole country we talk about leveling
up but that surely must be about the
people rather than the places i don't
think it's one bit of the country
against another i think the important
thing is everybody needs that
opportunity to succeed now and that's
the one thing about boris he's very keen
that you know business should be paying
the proper salary do you think do you
think the south east is overheated to
use their friends i don't know i haven't
really seen that i mean i i've you know
i've been volunteering in a food bank so
i've seen it from the bottom up well
exactly that's my point that you know
that in the end
this does end up being a little bit
north-south
the issue of leveling up whereas we do
have a lot of poverty in the south as
well yes but i mean we you know london
has traditionally been the engine of our
economy but if you look at something
like tfl that buys things that you know
we all use from across the country
actually there's plenty of opportunities
if you look at the supply chain for the
whole country to prosper and andy
burnham today who actually has been
quite warm at times about michael gove
and boy johnson
promising that as far as the northern
powerhouse is concerned
transforming transport in the in the
north that doesn't seem to be happening
now
well i hope it does because actually
those people deserve jobs they deserve
better transport systems i mean anybody
can go north south really easily in this
country but if you talk to those people
who are trying to still go east-west and
get around we desperately need a new
transport system you know linking
going east-west and west east up in the
north so i do hope very much indeed that
there is some investment and in you know
in increased infrastructure in the north
and how do you feel about the the
criticism of business i mean we we've
got used to referring to the
conservative party
as the party of business but now we're
apparently being told that businesses
are lazy they haven't invested they
haven't paid their workers what they
should uh any problems in the supply
chain are their fault is that really a
message you'd expect to come from a
conservative prime minister i agree with
you i don't think so i think the point
is that boris has always felt that if
you know that your wages should enable
you to thrive to enable you to prosper
not just to survive i think boris has
always felt it very disappointing that
the state has had to rather than just
focusing on all those who really don't
have any money and really do need
genuine support he was always felt that
we should be a better better wage a
higher wage economy after all when he
was mayor he raised the london living
wage and i have no doubt there will be
plans to go on raising the wages because
he wants people to to do well he wants
people to thrive and prosper but do you
think business owners and managers
have been derelict in their duty which
is what he appears to be saying
i think that's very unfair i mean during
the pandemic of course the government
has supported businesses to furlough and
i think that's why probably we're now in
the right position to make the best
opportunities of what's coming up what's
going to come up you know there's plenty
of vacancies you know businesses are
bouncing back perhaps bouncing back
faster than people had thought which is
why of course there's demand now for the
jobs and that's why there's a bit of a
catch up but that's also a global
situation i think but
you see if if things have gone badly
wrong
after 10 years of conservative
government you talked about boris
johnson in london
it has to be
on the conservative ticket that things
have gone wrong
things have gone wrong i mean that's why
that's what he's saying about businesses
he's saying that they're not paying what
they should be paying they haven't got
organized so that there's been problems
with truckers it's nothing to do with
him i mean that is blaming business
isn't it i think there is going to be a
bit of a catch-up i mean inevitably
because you know if you go if you go
into the building industry they tell you
there's things that have got to be
caught up with some delays but those
aren't just in the uk so i don't think
you should blame english businesses or
british businesses that's what he's
doing that's what i'm saying i don't i'm
not absolutely sure that's the case
because that's what lord wolfson feels
well yes um good old good next we're all
right next i think the thing is that
we've got to give everybody the
opportunity to get back and be
successful again i don't think the
conservatives should be blaming business
i certainly and i don't think they are
because after all you know a lot of
these people here are in business what
about farmers you know they were told
that they would be protected that things
would be better than they were under the
common agricultural policy and now we've
got
farmers unable to harvest all their
crops we've got apparently a mass waste
of
pigs about to take place i mean you know
well i enjoy my bacon and eggs so i
don't want that to happen but i am
somebody who walks down the supermarket
shells and tries to buy british because
i think it's important we should support
our farming industry and our fishing
industry yeah but the point is you're
not
well what we're saying that's what
they're saying
just over there we need the things in
the shops and we need to train our and
give our own people the opportunity of
having those jobs yes we may have to
have some short-term visas but actually
we should stop saying um that we've
always got to get people from overseas
yes we do want great talent from
overseas yes i believe in immigration i
do firmly believe it benefits our
country but actually where i where i do
want is i'd want our own company our own
young people to have the opportunity of
training whether it's apprenticeships or
training to do all the jobs that are
going to fill the skills gap at the
moment
okay victoria and then we're going to be
talking further once we hear the speech
because although we're able to give you
lines and quotes that we expect the
prime minister to say uh believe me
there's always a little bit extra uh
when the speeches are delivered which
could set the tone rather differently
now as we've seen the prime minister is
now here
in
the conference hall and seeing other
ministers coming across there oliver
dowden
uh there and uh the chancellor rishi
sunak uh olive dad and of course now a
co-chair of the uh conservative party
along with ben elliott rather shadowy
presence who you may have seen refuse to
talk to our
correspondent joe pike and there is
sanji javid
the health secretary who has been
saying that the health service should
refer to women as women uh
wouldn't have been a controversial
statement too many uh uh too long ago
but perhaps it is now there's dominic
robb just as secretary
uh he's he spoke yesterday about uh
wanting to revise britain's
participation in the european convention
on human rights
but
here with me now
is robert generick who of course
until recently was the housing
communities and local government
secretary now
uh back uh to uh
relative obscurity does does that hurt a
lot um well i think having done almost
more early morning starts on sky news
than any of my cabinet colleagues in the
last year or two i'm looking forward to
a bit of a break hopefully not for too
long though yeah you're having did you
have difficulty getting in we were
expecting a bit i mean it's sort of high
security here is that what's going on it
is there's a lot of people here so i
think everyone's pretty excited about
the promise of speech in a few minutes
time now on the area that you you were
concentrating on as a minister this
whole question of
housing and and where new houses are
going to be built are you any clearer
after this conference than the
government was before
well we'll have to wait and see the new
secretary of state michael gove's
obviously reviewing the proposals and i
think we'll set out his thoughts soon i
think you'll be a missed opportunity if
we didn't take forward some of those
proposals because as conservatives of
course we care about getting young
people onto the housing ladder and one
of the big issues of this conference and
the time to come is the cost of living
and of course one of the big costs to
households particularly in some parts of
the country is the cost of housing so we
need to take action on that but that's
just one part of the broader vision that
i think the prime minister will be
setting out later today for the country
the economy post covid but as you know
in in you know many leafy showers
there's resistance
to the building of new homes
and we've got the prime minister now
apparently talking about the southeast
being overheated
does that suggest now that the settled
view
is that new houses should be encouraged
away from the southeast and not built in
the southeast well my view is that they
need to be built in all parts of the
country because housing costs people so
much money and if you want to help their
pockets then you need to ensure that
homes are being built into places
including
where
they're already very expensive but
one of the features of this conference
has been
returning to the leveling up agenda
saying how we're going to deliver that
in the years ahead and part of that is
of course
reducing those regional inequalities
making it more attractive for a young
person born in manchester or where i was
in wolverhampton to stay local to make a
success of their life and access all
those opportunities and that includes
good quality housing in those places not
just in the overheated south east but
well you agree that you think the whole
southeast is overheated do you of course
house prices extremely high there's a
lot of pressure from development
it would be better for the country if we
were able to spread those opportunities
more broadly throughout the united
kingdom so that you would have the good
quality access to jobs to skills to
transport to culture and to housing uh
in places like i mean what i find
interesting about this argument is that
yes boris johnson built his majority
by breaking the red wall and taking
seats in the north but we we know where
the heartlands of the tory vote have
been historically
and it just seems to me that
those people if anything have been
criticized and and there's not much in
them in in it for them uh in what's been
proposed by mr johnson and so that
perhaps we might see a whole switch in
the tory party from the traditional
support possibly even
you know relatively privileged place but
people with with sort of backgrounds
perhaps similar to ours to a completely
different group of people but but that
is quite precarious isn't it to do that
struggle well the argument that the
prime minister has made is that
levelling up is a win-win for all
parties
but is it well i think that's right
because if you're concerned about over
development or the cost of living in a
place like london or the south east then
part of the answer of course is to build
more homes and infrastructure and get
good quality jobs into that part of
country but it's also to relieve
pressure on it by ensuring that other
parts of the country have access to the
same opportunities and that's the agenda
i think the prime minister is going to
be setting out later today
are you troubled though when you hear
the criticism of business when you hear
the criticism of farmers i mean a lot of
farmers in your constituency is that
fair that it's their fault somehow
what's happening to them
well what we need now are policies which
will boost economic growth
we want to see a higher wage economy
that is going to be one of the big
arguments the prime minister will make
today and has been throughout this
conference the way to do that
is to improve productivity and therefore
we need to grow the economy to invest in
skills and have a more innovative and
dynamic country
that is the agenda the vision that i
think the prime minister is going to set
out later today and if we can achieve
that and there are good signs at the
moment with real wages starting to rise
a lot of jobs being created in parts of
the country then we'll be delivering on
our promise to level up in time for the
next election robert generic thank you
very much i think you're telling me
you're hoping to get back in the cabinet
you haven't given up i certainly haven't
given up no i'm committed to
the country and to the party thank you
very much
indeed well uh my colleague kate mccann
has now moved towards the conference
hall and is speaking to the people who
are still filing in at what's going to
be a crowded room to listen to the prime
minister kate
hi adam yes you might be able to hear
you'll definitely be able to hear the
clapping of the audience here that's
because the cabinet has just arrived in
the hall ahead of boris johnson's speech
we expect the prime minister here in
just a few moments time but his cabinet
have filed in they've taken their seats
on the front row as has carrie johnson
the prime minister's wife just ahead of
this speech you'll be able to see that
familiar slogan there on the signage
behind the podium this of course is an
auditorium that no other cabinet
minister has used so far during this
party conference they've all been
speaking from a different auditorium
inside the hall this one purely for the
prime minister and you may well be able
to see around me i'm not sure if
anybody's holding them up quite yet but
there are lots of signs on seats lots of
slogans that members of the audience
here are going to be holding up we
expect during the speech they go there's
one of them getting on with the job lots
of those slogans that you're used to
hearing from the prime minister but
members here businesses people around
the country will want to hear more than
just those slogans i want to hear what
those policies are how that's going to
translate into what leveling up really
means for people around the country i
think adam were preparing for the prime
minister to arrive now here in the hall
you can things have got a little bit
quieter and you can see all those press
photographers there in the background
just behind me they're all crowding
round some of the cabinet particularly
the prime minister's wife harry johnson
of course is here you can see rishi
sunak the chancellor oliver dad and the
chairman of the party michael gove also
here liz truss on the front row it
really is one of the biggest moments for
the party for the prime minister too
remember this is the first conference
after that general election win in 2019
there is a real mood of optimism here
among the party but there are still big
questions about what's going to happen
off the back of this speech and whether
what the prime minister delivers here is
going to translate and change the way
people feel around the country
particularly adam some of those red raw
voters who gave their votes lent their
votes in the prime minister's own words
to the conservative party for the first
time
right okay well we can have a chat yeah
thank you very much indeed uh kate for
that uh people still filing in but uh
the conservative party organizers tell
us that they are still optimistic uh
that the prime minister uh will start at
half past uh so only a few minutes to go
uh well let's uh
pick up now uh a little bit on uh
some of the
views uh that are being made about this
conservative party conference joining me
are the
ex-conservative mp and ex-deputy mayor
uh victoria boyk and also brian
shorthouse founder and ceo of bright
blue and also conservative party advisor
let's just
run through some of the comments that we
normally do at this time on all our
politics looking
at this conference in the guardian the
labour mayor of greater manchester andy
burnham tells the prime minister today
is the day to make leveling up really
happen
and their uh
columnist and wit marina hyde also
focuses on events here she says that
seeing rishi soon i can actually
manchester was all a bit simba goes to
conference as she describes boris
johnson uh as uh the young lion king's
uncle scar
in the times daniel finkelstein focuses
on talk of a high wage economy and asks
how do we pay for it
the papers cartoon has pretty patel
blasting and insulate britain
protester who's holding up traffic how
dare you prevent free movement she says
but the next picture she's blocking
blocking a van from the european union
no more free movement are her words this
time in dante in the eye says the home
secretary's response to the
demonstrators is taking away the right
to protest with potentially far-reaching
consequences philip johnson in the
telegraph believes the mood is bullish
here in manchester but he warns the
tories are in for what he describes as a
self-created mess on public spending the
telegraph cartoon has the blame game
over the supply crisis the prime
minister and the head of the business
body the cbi are both seen walking away
having stuck blaming notes on each
other's backs
well we're waiting as i said for the
switch but let's get the thoughts so i
mean ryan shaw house
for a tory conference and tory papers
it's not not a great set of uh comment
is it
no and i mean there's two things really
one is the kind of new health and social
care levy a new tax tories are allergic
to taxes and that's you know that's sort
of hanging over a lot of fringe events
the other thing is leveling up
everyone's talking about leveling up
every fringe event no matter what the
topic what is leveling up how do we do
it and you know the prime minister did a
speech in the summer about that and as
andy burnham said in his column today
it's very vague it's very woolly still
but i think what most people understand
it to be is helping those kind of left
behind areas particularly in coastal
former industrial areas i agree i
disagree with andy when he says it's
about the north of england those areas
also exist in the south but we need to
have delivery on that the prime minister
has said you know 2019 a lot of those
voters in those areas lent their votes
to the tory government for the first
time in ages now he has to deliver and
we still haven't really had any meat
behind that and i'm interested too that
lord finkelstein danny finkelstein
victory a little bit skeptical about
this saying you know where's the money
to pay the higher wages
well i mean i think the point is he
wants it to come from business you know
he sees us being a high-skilled
high-wage economy and less dependent on
the welfare state being used to do to
help those who really do need it and i
think the point you've made is there are
those there's poverty everywhere in the
country and we've got to be helped
everybody get back into work we know the
jobs are there now we've just got to
help people get back into work around do
you think there's truth in what philip
johnson says that you know at any party
conference the party looks at itself
leadership
who are the up and coming stars and all
that and actually gets a bit out of
touch and when you and when you happen
to be in government you know you get
back to westminster or your
constituencies and you know they're real
problems that could could start dragging
on the government yeah i would say there
is a bit of a tiredness to this
government in terms of new ideas i think
back when cameron came into coalition
lots of new stuff free schools uc there
just isn't that newness and kind of
raising the minimum wage is not
necessarily a you know that was
introduced by a labor government back in
the in back in the 90s which the tories
opposed back then so there isn't a kind
of freshness to this and the leveling up
stuff you know this kind of pots of
funding which to be honest that's been
tried since the 60s pretty marginal
effects so if the government's really
going to transform these communities
it's got to do something big and we
haven't seen that yet i'd like to
challenge you on that because i think
we're just about to see a really
empowering passionate speech i mean i
know boris is passionate and i know he
wants this country to be successful so i
think we're going to see we are going to
see some new ideas and i think the
wonderful thing here is the fact that is
a more intimate conference is that the
volunteers have been able to talk
directly to their mps the people they
voted for the people they supported and
supported them so that's been a great
opportunity to put their ideas in and i
think it's been a collaborative
conference and i hope that bodes well as
we've you know won the battle of the
pandemic we've now got to win the piece
we've got to get the country going again
and i'm sure we're going to see great
energy from boris as he enlightened well
let's see
here he is
energetically walking into the specially
constructed conference or getting a
standing invasion before he starts
the leader of the conservative party uh
boris johnson
make his way to podium kissing uh his
wife
not taking much notice of pretty patel
the home secretary
[Applause]
but now his uh
address to conference first time in two
years he's had the chance to do this uh
in person because of course of covid
good morning good morning everybody
good morning everyone
fantastic to see you all here thank you
thank you let's
let's get going let's get let's let's
get on with the drop
go
go good morning everybody listen isn't
it amazing to be back here in person and
the first time the first time since
so many of you work to defy the skeptics
by winning councils and communities that
conservatives have never won in before
such as hartlepool
and in fact
it's the first time since the general
election of 2019
when we finally sent that corduroy
communist cosmonaut
into orbit where he belongs
and why is it that we are back today for
a traditional
conservative cheek by jowla
it's because for months
we have had one of the most open
economies and societies and on july the
19th we decided to open every single
theater
and every concert hall and nightclub in
england
and we knew
that some people would still be anxious
so we sent top government
representatives to our sweatiest what de
nuit to show that anyone could dance
perfectly safely
and wasn't he brilliant my friend
let's hear it
let's hear it for john von goby
living proof
living proof that we
we you all
represent the most
jiving hip happening and generally funka
potterson party in the world and
how have we managed to open up ahead of
so many of our friends
you know the answer it's because of the
rollout of that vaccine
a uk phenomenon the magic potion
invented in oxford university bottled in
wales distributed at incredible speed to
vaccination centers everywhere i saw the
army in action in glasgow
firing staple guns like carbines as they
set up a huge vaccination center
in for mana i saw the needles go in like
a collective sewing machine they
vaccinated so rapidly
that we were able to do those crucial
groups one to four
the oldest and most vulnerable
faster than any other major economy in
the world
and though the disease has sadly not
gone away
the impact
[Applause]
the impact on the impact on death rates
has been is astonishing and i urge you
all
uh to i urge you all to get uh your jabs
because
every day our vaccine defenses are
getting stronger and stronger and you
you all of you and everybody watching
you made this roll out possible
you made each other
safer
so perhaps we should all thank each
other
go on try it
i mean
you can try it try a cautious try a
cautious fist bump
because it's okay now and we in turn
thank the volunteers the public health
workers the council workers the
pharmacists
but above all
our untiring
unbeatable unbelievable
nhs
[Applause]
and
as a responsible conservative government
we must recognize the sheer scale of
their achievement but also the scale of
the challenge ahead
when i was lying in st thomas's hospital
last year
i looked blurrily out of my window at a
hole in the ground between the the icu
and another much older victorian section
and amid the rubble of brick they seem
to be digging
a hole
for someone or something or indeed
someone
possibly me
but the nhs saved me and our wonderful
nurses pulled my chestnuts out of that
tartarian pit and
i went back on a visit the other day
and i saw that the hole had been filled
in with three or four gleaming stories
of a new pediatrics unit and there you
have a meta for my friends for how we
must build back better now we have a
huge hole in the public finances we
spent 407 billion pounds on covid
support and our debt now stands at over
2 trillion pounds
and waiting lists will almost certainly
go up before they come down
kovid pushed out a great bow wave of
cases people did not or could not seek
help and that wave is now coming back
a tide of anxiety washing into every a e
and every gp
your hip replacement your mother's
surgery and this is the priority of the
british people
does anyone seriously imagine that we
should not now be raising the funding to
sort this out is that really the view of
responsible conservatives i can tell you
something margaret thatcher would not
have ignored the meteorite that has just
crashed through the public finances she
would have wagged her finger
and said more borrowing now
is just higher interest rates and even
higher taxes later
when this country was sick
our nhs was the nurse
frontline care workers battled against a
new disease selflessly risking their
lives sacrificing their lives and it is
right that this party that has looked
after the nhs for most of its history
should be the one to rise to the
challenge 48 new hospitals 50 000 more
nurses 50 million more gp appointments
40 new diagnostic centers and fixing
those backlogs with real change because
the pandemic not only put colossal
pressure on the nhs it was a lightning
flash illumination of a problem we have
failed to address for decades
in 1948 this country created the
national health service but kept social
care local although that made sense in
many ways generations
of older people have found themselves
lost in the gap
when kobe broke the 100 000 beds in the
nhs
and 30 000
occupied by people who could have been
cared for elsewhere whether at home
or in residential care
and we all know that this problem of
delayed discharge is one of the major
reasons why it takes too long to get the
hospital treatment that your family
desperately need and people worry that
they will be the one there they will be
the one in ten to suffer from the
potentially catastrophic cost of
dementia
wiping out everything they have and
preventing them from passing on anything
to their families
are we conservatives stand by those who
have shared our values
thrift and hard work
and who face total destitution in this
brutal lottery of old age in which
treatment for cancer is funded by the
state and care for alzheimer's is not or
only partly
and to fix these twin problems of the
nhs and social care we aren't just going
to siphon billions of new taxes into
crucial services without improving
important performance we will use new
technology so that there is a single set
of electronic records as patients pass
between health and social care improving
care and ensuring that cash goes to the
front line and not on needless
bureaucracy
when i stood
on the steps
[Applause]
when i stood on the steps of downing
street i promised to fix this crisis and
after decades of drift and dither this
reforming government this can do
government this government that got
brexit done that's getting the covid
vaccine rollout done is going to get
social care done and we are going to
deal with the biggest underlying issues
of our economy and society the problems
that no government has had the guts to
tackle before and i mean the long-term
structural weaknesses in the uk economy
it's thanks to the vaccine rollout that
we now have the most open open economy
and the fastest growth in the g7 we have
unemployment
we have unemployment two million lower
than forecast we have demand surging and
i'm pleased to say that after years of
stagnation more than a decade wages are
going up faster than before the pandemic
began and that matters deeply because we
are embarking now on a change of
direction that has been long overdue in
the uk economy we're not going back to
the same old broken model with low wages
low growth low skills and low
productivity all of it enabled and
assisted by uncontrolled immigration
and the answer
to the present stresses and strains
which are mainly a function of growth
and economic revival
is not to reach for that same old lever
of uncontrolled immigration to keep
wages low
the answer
is to control immigration to allow
people of talent to come to this country
but not to use immigration as an excuse
for failure to invest in people in
skills and in the equipment the
facilities the machinery
[Applause]
or in the machinery the facilities they
knew they need to do their jobs
the truck stops the truck stops to pick
an
example entirely at random with basic
facilities where you don't have to
urinate in the bushes and that is the
direction in which this country is going
now towards a high wage high skill high
productivity and yes thereby a low tax
economy that is what the people of this
country need and deserve
in which everyone
can take pride in their work and in the
take pride in their work and in the
quality of their work and yes it will
take time and sometimes it will be
difficult but that was the change that
people voted for in 2016 and that was
the change that people voted for again
powerfully in 2019 and to deliver that
change we will get on with our job of
uniting and leveling up across the uk
the greatest project that any government
can embark on
we have one of the most imbalanced
societies
and lopsided economies of all the richer
countries
it's not just that there's a gap between
london and the south east and the rest
of the country there are aching gaps
within the regions themselves
what monkey glands are they applying in
rebel valley what royal jelly are they
eating that they live seven years longer
than the people of blackpool only 33
miles away why does half of york's
population boast a degree and only a
quarter of doncasters that is not just a
question of social justice it is an
appalling waste of potential and it is
holding this country back
[Applause]
because there is no reason why the
inhabitants of one part of the country
should be geographically fated to be
poorer than others or why people should
feel they have to move away from their
loved ones or communities to reach their
potential
when thomas gray stood in that country
churchyard in 1750
and wrote his famous elegy as the curfew
told the nail of parting day
he lamented the wasted talents of those
buried around him the flowers born to
blush unseen
the muting glorious miltons
who never wrote a poem
because they never got to read
the simple folk who died illiterate and
enumerate and he knew that that was an
injustice let me ask you
maybe you know
where was he standing
when he chewed his pensive quill
anybody know
correct he was stan thank you he was
standing in the in stoke poaches
my friends there may be many under par
there may be underprivileged parts of
our country but stoke pogees is not now
among them in fact it was only recently
determined by the daily telegraph and
you can't believe that what can you
believe my friends to be the eighth
the eighth richest village in england
since grey energized buckinghamshire has
leveled up to be among the most
productive regions in the whole of
europe stoke poaches may still of course
have its problems but they are
overwhelmingly caused by the sheer lust
of other people to live in or near stoke
bogeys
overcrowded trains endless commutes too
little time with the kids the constant
anxiety that your immemorial view of
chalk downland is going to be desecrated
by ugly new homes and that is why
leveling up works for the whole country
and it is the right and responsible
policy because it helps to take the
pressure off parts of the overheating
south east while simultaneously offering
hope and opportunity to those areas that
have felt left behind and let's be clear
that there is a huge philosophical
difference between us and labour because
in their souls
they don't like leveling up
they don't like level up
they like leveling down
they do
they
they like
they like decapitating the tall poppies
and squee and taxing the rich till the
pips squeak and they dislike academic
competition latin i hear and in
islington i kid you not i've seen it
with my own eyes they like kids to run
races i've seen this where nobody
actually wins
and i i have to tell you i don't think
that is a good preparation for life let
alone for the olympic games
[Applause]
and if you if you insist on the economic
theory behind leveling up it is it
contained in the inside of wilfredo
pareto
a 19th century italian figure who
floated from the cobwebbed attic of my
my my memories there are all kinds of
improvements that you can make to
people's lives he said without
diminishing everyone else i wish you
will i'm sure
confirm this we call these pareto
improvements right and they are the
means of leveling up and the idea in a
nutshell is that you will find talent
genius flair imagination enthusiasm
everywhere in this country all of them
evenly distributed evenly distributed
but opportunity is not and it is our
mission as conservatives to promote
opportunity with every tool we have
and it is still a grim fact that uh in
this country
some
that's right
it's it's all about opportunity
but it's still a grim fact that in this
country some kids will grow up in
neighborhoods that are much safer than
others and some will be as pretty was
saying some will be sucked into gang
some will be at risk of
stabbing and shooting some will get
themselves caught in the one-way ratchet
of the criminal justice system many
others will not
and that's why leveling up means
fighting crime putting more police out
on the beat as we are
toughening sentences rolling up the
county lines drugs networks as we are
one thousand one hundred of them gone
already
giving the police the powers they need
to fight these dealers in death and
misery that's what we want to do and
what's labor's answer by the way to
decriminalize hard drugs apparently to
let the gangsters off with a caution an
answer that is straight from the powder
rooms of north london dinner parties and
nothing to do with the real needs of
this country
[Applause]
it's true
crime
crime has been falling
uh and i and not just by the way because
we took the precaution of locking up the
public for much of the last 18 months
but because you have a conservative
government that understands the broken
windows theory of fighting crime i read
a learned article by some lawyer saying
we shouldn't bother about pet theft
pet theft
well i say to cruella deville qc
if
if you can steal a dog or a cat then
there is frankly no limit to your
depravity and and
and you know
[Applause]
and you know those people you know
there's people gluing themselves to to
roads i don't call them legitimate
protesters
like some labour councillors do i think
some labour councils actually glue
themselves around i say there are
confounded nuisance who are blocking
ambulances stopping people going about
their daily lives
i'm glad
and i'm glad pretty is taking new powers
taking new powers to insulate them
snugly in prison where they belong
what i find
[Applause]
what i find most incredible of all was
the decision by labor now led by
lefty islington lawyers
to vote against
tougher sentences for serious sexual and
violent offenders
and on behalf of the entire government i
tell you this
we will not rest
until we have increased the successful
prosecutions for rape
because too many
[Applause]
too many
lying bullying cowardly men are using
the law's delay to get away with
violence against women and we cannot and
we will not stand for it
and
[Applause]
i know that
there are some who
who tell us that we are you know that
we're we're being ungenerous and
unfeeling in our attempts to control our
borders and i say don't give me that
this is the government that stood up to
china and announced that we would
provide a haven for british overseas
nationals from hong kong 30 000 have
already applied and i'm proud to be to
be part
i'm really proud
to be part of a conservative government
that will welcome 20 000 afghans people
who risk their lives to guide and
translate for us
we are doing
the right
and
responsible thing and speaking as the
great grandson of a turk who fled in
fear of his life i know that this
country is a beacon of light and hope
for people around the world provided
they come here legally provided we
understand who they are and what they
want to contribute
and that's why
we took back control of our borders and
will pass the borders bill because we
believe there must be a distinction
between someone who comes here legally
and someone who doesn't and though i
have every sympathy with people
genuinely in fear of their lives i have
no sympathy whatever with the people
traffickers who take thousands of pounds
to send children to sea in frail and
dangerous craft and we must end this
lethal trade we must break the gangsters
business model
and
is it not a sublime irony
is it not a sublime irony that even in
french politics there is now a leading
centre-right politician calling for a
referendum on the eu
who is now calling for france to
rapunzel control
it's good old michelle barnier
that's what happens
that's what happens if you spend a year
trying to argue with lord frost
the greatest frost
since the great frost of 1709
and
we will we will fight these gangs at
home and abroad because their victims
are invariably the poorest and the
neediest and i'll tell you what leveling
up is
a few years ago they started a school
not far from the olympic park a new
school anyone could send their kids to
in an area that for decades has been one
of the most disadvantaged in london
that school is brampton manor academy
and it now sends more kids to oxbridge
than eaton and if you want proof of what
i mean by unleashing potential and by
leveling up look at brampton manor and
we can do it there is absolutely no
reason why the kids of this country
should lag behind or why so many should
be unable to read or write or do basic
mathematics at 11 and to level up to
level up on top of the extra 14 billion
we're putting into education
on top of the increase that means every
teacher starts with a salary of 30 000
pounds we're announcing today a leveling
up premium of up to three thousand
pounds to send the best maths and
science teachers to the places that need
the most and above all we are investing
[Applause]
we're investing in us
we're investing in our skills
skills folks our universities are world
beating i i i owe everything to my to my
tutors then they're one of the great
glories of our economy but we all know
that some of the most brilliant and
imaginative and creative people in
britain some of the best paid people in
britain
did not go to university
and to level up you need to give people
the options the skills that are right
for them and to make the most of those
skills and knowledge you need urgently
to plug all the other gaps
in the infrastructure that are still
holding uh people and communities back
as i've been saying over the over this
wonderful conference uh to you when i
became leader of this party there were
only can you remember what percentage of
of of uh households had gigabit
broadband when you were so kind as to
make me leader
sarah you've been paying attention some
of you this
seven percent only seven percent they're
absolutely right and what will it be by
the new year
actually i'm told tonight 68
by the by the new year and thanks to
thanks to rishi's
thanks to rishi's thanks to rishi's
super deduction the pace is now
accelerating massively as companies
thrust the fiber optic vermicelli in the
most hard to reach places and
it's wonderful for years uh the snp
leader in westminster ian blackford has
been telling the commons that he is
nothing
but a humble crofter
on the isle of skye
well now that we have fiber optic
broadband uh of
of a very high quality we can inspect
the library or or is it or is it perhaps
the billiard room
urban blackfood's croft and that is
leveling up in action and
[Applause]
my friends
it's it's not good enough it's not good
enough just to rely on zoom after
decades of duct decisions our national
infrastructure is way behind some of our
key competitors it's a disgrace that you
still can't swiftly cross the penins by
rail the disgrace that leeds is the
largest city in europe with no proper
metro system a waste of human potential
but so many places are not served by
decent bus routes transport is one of
the supreme leveler uppers and we are
making the big generational changes
shirked by previous governments we will
do northern powerhouse rail we will link
up the cities of the midlands at the
north we will restore those sinews of
the union that have been allowed to
atrophy the a1 north of beric and on
into scotland the a75 in scotland are so
vital for the links with with northern
ireland and the rest of the country the
north wales corridor
yes
and we will invest in our roads
unblocking those coagulated roundabouts
and steering wheel bending traffic
lights with four putting on four
thousand more clean green buses made in
this country some of them running on
hydrogen and as we as we come out of
kobe
as we come out of kobe our towns and
cities are going to be buzzing with life
because we know that a productive
workforce needs the spur that only comes
with face-to-face meetings and water
cooler gossip if young people are to
learn on the job in the way that they
always have and must we will and must
see people back in the office and that
is why
and that is why we are building back
better
that is why we are building back better
with a once in a century 640 billion
pound program of investment and by
making neighborhoods safer by putting in
the gigabit broadband by putting in the
roads and the schools and the healthcare
we will enable more young people
everywhere to share the dream of
homeownership the great ambition of the
human race that the left always
privately share but publicly disparage
and we can do it
look at this country from the air go on
google maps
you see how our landscape has been
plotted and pieced and jigsawed together
by centuries of bequests and litigation
a vast testament to security of title
trust in the law and it's a confidence
that is responsible for so much
international investment you see how
rich this country is growing the
billions of loving and incremental
improvements to homes and gardens you
can see how beautiful it is fast
untouched moorland hills and broadleaf
forests we are going to rewild parts of
the country and consecrate a total of 30
to nature we're planting tens of
millions of trees otters are returning
to rivers from which they've been absent
for decades beavers that have not been
seen on some rivers since tudor times
massacred for their pelts and now back
and if that isn't conservatism my
friends i don't know what is bill back
fever i say
build back beaver i know that
though the beavers
though the beavers may sometimes build
without without local authority
permission you can also see you can also
see how much room there is to build the
homes that young families need in this
country not on greenfield not just
jammed in the south east but beautiful
homes on brownfield sites in places
where homes make sense and
this government
this government is helping young people
to afford a home it's been a scandal a
rebuke to all we stand for that over the
last 20 years the dream of homeownership
has receded and yet under this
government we are turning the tide we've
not only built more homes than any time
in the last 30 years we're helping young
people onto the property ladder with our
95 mortgages and there is no happiness
like taking a set of keys and knowing
the place is yours
and you can paint the front door any
color you like
as it happens i can't i can't paint my
own front door any color i like has to
be black but i certainly don't have to
go very far to work
and if you don't have to go far to work
and your commute isn't too dreadful and
if the job suits your skills and your
wi-fi is fast and reliable i'll tell you
something else that housing
in the right place and at an affordable
price will add massively not just to
your general juan of eve but your
productivity and that is how we solve
the national productivity puzzle by
fixing the broken housing market
by plugging in the gigabit
by putting in decent safe bus routes and
all the other transported infrastructure
and investing in skills skills skills
[Applause]
and that by the way is how we help to
cut the cost of living for everyone
because housing energy transport are now
huge parts of our monthly bills and it's
by fixing our broken housing market
sorting out our energy supply more wind
more
more nuclear
becoming less dependent on hydrocarbons
from abroad by putting in those
transport links we will hold costs down
and save you money and we will make this
country an even more attractive
destination for foreign direct
investment we're already number one look
at the nissan investment in sunderland
the fisa vaccine manufacturing centre
that's coming to swindon and
with these productivity gains we will
turbo charge that advantage and help
businesses to start and grow everywhere
so let me come now to the punchline of
my sermon on the vaccine it was not
it was not the government that made the
wonder drug it wasn't brewed in the
alembics of the department of health
it was
of course it was oxford university but
it was the private sector that made it
possible behind those vaccines are
companies and shareholders and yes
bankers unique deep pools of liquidity
that are to be found in the city of
london it was capitalism that ensured we
had a vaccine in less than a year and
the answer therefore is not to attack
the wealth creators it's to encourage
them because they are responsible for
the aggregate increase in the country's
wealth that enables us to make those
pareto improvements and to level up
everywhere and
to rub home my point
it is not just it is not just that
vaccination has saved more than 120 000
lives
vaccination has allowed us to meet like
this and blessed us with such rapid
growth with wages rising fastest for
those on lowest incomes and that is
leveling up in action these vaccines
have ensured that by a simple vowel
mutation jabs jabs jabs become jobs jobs
jobs the world's most effective vaccines
have saved
have saved our open society and free
market economy and it is our open
society and free market economy that
have produced the world's most effective
vaccines and that is the symmetry in the
lesson of the kobe vaccine science
innovation capitalism is vital now
for the challenge that we face uh is the
chance the whole of humanity faces is
now even more existential for our way of
life in just a few weeks this
country will host the summit of our
generation in glasgow when the resolve
of the world
is put to the test
can we keep alive the ambition of paris
to stop the planet heating by more than
one and a half degrees while government
can't do it alone and taxpayers
certainly can't do it alone
the other day i took a boat out into the
into the murray firth to see this
aquatic forest of white turbines
towering over the water like the
redwoods of california and you have no
idea of their size until you see them up
close the deceptive speed of their wings
twice the twice the the diameter of the
london eye and their tips slicing
through the air at more than 100 miles
an hour and i met the young men and
women apprentices who had moved straight
across from the world of oil and gas
and they had the same excitement at
working amid winds and waves and the lt
whales and dolphins from the office
window
but they had that extra satisfaction
that goes with knowing you're doing
something to save the planet
and get britain to net zero by 2050 and
that is the symmetry represented by
these these giant windmills massive and
innovative private sector investment and
a government taking the tough decisions
to make it possible and that's the
difference between this radical and
optimistic conservatism and a tired old
labor did you see them last week did you
watch them last week in in in brighton
hopelessly would hopelessly divided i
thought they looked their leader like a
seriously rattled bus conductor
pushed this way and that by not that
they have bus conductors anymore
unfortunately but now a serious a
seriously rattled bus conductor pushed
this thing this way this way and that by
a corbin easter mob of sellotape
spectacled solute or the
or the skipper of a cruise liner that's
been captured by somali pirates
desperately trying to negotiate a change
of course and then changing his mind and
remember labour's performance during the
pandemic flapping with all the
conviction of a damp tea tile they
refused to say that that schools were
safe uh they would have kept us in the
european medicines agency and they
slammed the brakes on the vaccine
rollout their the the labor leader
attacked the vaccine task force for
spending money on outreach to vaccine
hesitant minority groups when it's hard
to think of any better use of public
money and let us forgive him on the
basis he probably didn't know what he
was talking about but
it in in previous
[Applause]
in previous national crises labor
leaders have opted to minimize public
anxiety and confusion by not trying to
score cheap party political points by
thinks of uh of atlea or even michael
foote in the falklands crisis and sadly
that was not the approach taken by
captain heinz attacking one week rowing
in behind it when it seemed to be
working the human weathervane the the
starmer chameleon and in his final
absurd act of opportunism he decided to
oppose step four he opposed step four of
the road map in july remember that's
right folks if we listen to captain
hindsight today we'd still be in
lockdown we wouldn't have the fastest
growth in the g7 if columbus had
listened to captain hindsight he'd be
famous for having discovered tenerife
how utterly
absolutely
how utterly astonishing
[Applause]
how utterly astonishing that in the last
few weeks labor should actually have
voted against the funding we're putting
forward for the nhs and we need to
remember how and why we've been able to
back people through this pandemic at all
it was because we conservatives fixed
the economy we repaired the damage that
labor left behind every labour
government has left office with
unemployment higher than when it came in
every single one ever since the party
was invented and today we are going to
fix this economy and build back better
than ever before and just as we used our
new freedoms to accelerate the vaccine
rollout we're going to use brexit
freedoms to do things differently we
we've done that we're doing the borders
bill we've we've seen off the european
super league and protected grassroots
football we're doing at least
[Applause]
we're doing at least eight free ports
super super fertilized loam in which
business will be able to plant new jobs
across the uk and now we're going to go
further not only jettisoning
eu rules we don't need any more but
using new freedoms to improve the way we
regulate in the great growth areas of
the 21st century centuries we fulfill
our ambition of becoming a science
superpower gene editing data management
ai cyber quantum and we're going to be
ever more global in our outlook we've
done already 68 free trade deals
including that great free trade deal
with our friends in the eu which they
all said was impossible and after
decades of
bewildering refusal
we have persuaded
the americans
to import prime british beef
a market
a market already worth 66 million pounds
built back burger i say and how when you
ask yourself how the american how how
have the americans been able to be able
to survive without british beef for so
long if you want a supreme example of
global britain in action of something
daring and brilliant that would simply
not have happened if we'd remained in
the eu i give you
orcus
an idea so transparently right
an idea so transparently right that
labour conference voted overwhelmingly
against it
and i i know there has been a certain
raucous caucus from the antiochus caucus
but orcus
orcus is simply a recognition of the
reality that the world is tilting on its
axis on its economic axis and our trade
and relations in the indo-pacific region
are becoming more vital than ever before
that's why we sent our amazing carrier
strike group to the far east performing
maneuvers with 40 friendly countries hms
queen elizabeth as long as the entire
palace of westminster
and rather more compelling as an
argument than many of the speeches made
in the house of commons it has
it has dozens of f-35s
on board 66 000 sausages and not because
we want to threaten anyone or be
adversarial to anyone either with the
f-35s or indeed the sausages but because
we want to because we want to stick up
for the rule of law
that is so vital for freedom of
navigation and free trade
and that's what brings orcus together
australia uk us
shared values a shared belief in
democracy and human rights a shared
belief in the equal dignity and worth of
every human being
very few countries could have pulled off
the kabul airlift an astonishing feat by
our brave armed forces
even fewer
[Applause]
even fewer have the same moral
priorities no other government brokered
a deal such as this government did with
astrazeneca so that ox says the oxford
vaccine has been distributed at cost
around the world more than a billion
low-cost vaccines invented in britain
saving millions of lives
well led by our values by the things we
stand for and we should never forget
that people around the world admire the
this country for its its history
and traditions and they love the the
groovy new architecture and the fashion
and
and the music and uh and the
and all the rest of it uh the chance of
meeting the the the the
michael in the in the in the disco but
they they
they like it for the way it emerges
organically
the way all that emerges organically
from a vast inherited conglomerate of
culture and tradition
and we conservatives understand the need
for both
and how each nourishes the other and we
attack and deny our history at our peril
when they began to attack churchill as a
racist i was minded to ignore them
because it's only 20 years ago since bbc
audiences overwhelmingly voted in the
greatest britain of all time
because
he
[Applause]
he helped
he helped to defeat a regime after all
that was defined by one of the most
vicious racisms the world has ever seen
but as time has gone by it's become
clear to me that this isn't just a joke
they really do
want to rewrite our national story
starring uh starting with uh with hero
with the woke uh we really are we we
really are at risk of a kind of
know-nothing cancer culture uh
iconoclasm
and so we conservatives will defend our
history and cultural inheritance not
because
not is where pride
[Applause]
not because we're proud of everything
but because trying to edit it now is as
dishonest as a celebrity trying
furtively to change his entry in
wikipedia and it's a betrayal of our
children's education
churchill's last words to his cabinet
actually these whole ministers but never
mind this cabinet were there but never
be separated from the americans a pretty
good advice i think you'll agree and he
ended with the observation
man
is spirit
like he was right there didn't you
i believe that through history and
accident
this country has a unique spirit
the spirit of the nhs nurses
and
the entrepreneurs
whose innovative flair means that there
are
three countries in the world that have
produced more than 100 unicorns what i
mean by unicorn it's not a mythical
beast it's a tech company worth more
than a billion dollars each those three
countries have you been paying attention
they are the united states china and the
united kingdom
and
those unicorns
those unicorns are now dispersed around
the united kingdom in a way that is that
is new to our country it's fantastic to
see that leveling up
and we need the spirit of the nhs nurses
and the entrepreneurs because each
enables the other and i mean the spirit
of the the footballers who took england
into the final of a major knockout
tournament for the first time in the
lives of the vast majority of the of the
people of this country
and probably
looking around at you all you young
thrusters the majority of the people in
this room
the indomitable spirit of emma radicanu
her grace and her her mental resilience
[Applause]
when the game was going against her
because that is what counts
the spirit of our olympians it's an
incredible thing incredible thing to
come yet again in the top four a
formidable effort for a country that has
only 0.8
of the world's population in spite jacob
of all our best efforts but we
some of us
but when
but when we come second
but the point is that when we come
second in the paralympics as well
[Applause]
that shows our values
not only the the achievement of those
elite athletes but a country that is
proud to be a trailblazer to judge
people not by where they come from but
by their spirit and by what is inside
them that is the spirit that is the same
across this country in every town and
village and city that can be found in
the hearts and minds of kids growing up
everywhere and that is the spirit we are
going to unleash
thank you all thank you
rather soft ending to
his speech there now greeting is greeted
by his wife uh on the stage pat's worth
noting that he spoke for roughly half
the time that the labour leader uh spoke
last week and
even then uh towards the end he seemed a
little bit uh to be running out of
material
but
there were some important points
particularly in a strong opening to that
he began with the words let's get on
with the job
he celebrated the opening up
that britain had done following the kobe
pandemic ahead of others he said because
of the magic potion
of the astrazeneca
vaccine
he praised the nhs but also told the
party to
praise themselves
and then he got onto the main economic
section saying uh that
it was a moment to embrace change not to
the moment for the same old broken
economy of low wages and low
productivity
the answer to the present stresses and
strains the shortages he said is not
to reach for the lever of uncontrolled
immigration
but to invest in the country while we
can go now to our political
correspondent kate mccann who's in the
hall
with
the education secretary over to you kate
morning adam yes i am indeed here with
the education secretary nadim zahawi can
i just get your thoughts on that speech
from boris johnson
skills skills skills
education
is the building block for levelling up
that is the journey that we will go on
that is the journey that we will
complete
and i think
as the prime minister just set out my
department will be central the teachers
the support staff in schools in fe
colleges at universities the message
from here is we are going to invest in
skills for this country and have a high
wage
productive economy
like never before
he took us on a journey
and i think that journey from
brexit
to dealing with a global pandemic
to dealing with
adult social care
a vexing issue since i was a young man
attending conferences for many a
government he did all that today
and that sort of hope that spirit
of the vaccination program that
i used to refer to as a dunkirk spirit
the country coming together we had 80
000 people volunteer to become
vaccinators 250 000 people joined the
effort the public sector with the
private sector hand-in-hand vaccinated
protected country allowing us all to be
here to get our lives back and our
economy
really humming again so a tremendous i
think
philosophical message and a operational
on the ground delivery message of what
global britain will be like in the
future and the future of our children he
kept going back to education throughout
the whole speech
and in fact education there was only one
announcement in that speech and it was
on education on your brief on extra
money to get maths and science teachers
into the places where they are needed
were you hoping for perhaps a little bit
more on leveling up a little bit more
policy on exactly how that's going to
work there was only one announcement in
that speech
well i think that announcement was quite
important because actually it's that
3000 pounds to retain and to get new
teachers in those subjects where we have
shortages in the areas we require them
the most to help those children you know
he talks about opportunity not being
spread equally talent is but not
opportunity and of course we've got the
spending review to come but let's not
forget we've got three billion pounds
that i am now effectively
operationalizing and administering on
recovery the catch up and we've seen it
work
tutoring was for a very long time has
been for a long time the sort of remit
of wealthy families it's now available
to every child in the maintained sector
that's a great thing and you'll see us
go further on skills skill skills as he
said
but this speech was a bit of a risk
wasn't it because you said yourself it
was philosophical it was about setting a
narrative it was about throwing things
forward but there are lots of people
around the country who are feeling the
pinch right now not least those who've
lost that 20 pound a week universal
credit uplift today but also people who
are worried about fuel about energy
prices about how they're going to handle
things over christmas there's going to
be a gulf and a difficult period and the
prime minister himself said that that
people are going to have to grip their
teeth through do you think you're doing
enough to make sure that those at the
really at the bottom end who are really
struggling are going to be able to get
through these next couple of months well
i think he did two things i think he set
the narrative but also
shared with the country operationally
how we're going to do this and related
back to how we did the vaccine program
and i think
precisely on your point how do you
achieve a high-wage high-skilled economy
his message to business is invest and we
will back you invest capital
and
in the most valuable resource the human
resource put that investment in so that
wages do rise and businesses are doing
it look at the retailers that have
succeeded they're the ones who've
invested heavily in capital in
technology and in their people look at
i've got wilmore in my constituency one
of the biggest suppliers to the
supermarkets of fresh fruit and veg what
are they doing they're investing in
their people and in their machinery that
is what a dynamic high-skilled high-wage
economy looks like and what the prime
minister is saying is with the
chancellor with the home secretary of
the education secretary with the
business secretary we are all one team
that will deliver this
not just the narrative
but operationally
implementing this stuff to get there and
we are backing people to get higher
wages and backing business and he said
it in that speech to invest
and ultimately the success is lower
taxation so it's down to business not
government to make that gap feel less
difficult for those people at the bottom
it's a partnership
right there there is no that menacing
spoke about how we work with the private
sector the entrepreneurial spirit and
the spirit of the nurses in the nhs it
is a true partnership and coming
together and i've seen it in my own
constituencies i just described it i've
seen it here in manchester your big
logistics business investing in big
warehousing
increasing the level of skill of the
workforce and therefore wages as well as
bringing robots in it is that
combination that dynamism that
innovation in the uk and that delivery
that is what this government is about is
getting on with the job nadine zaharawi
thank you very much adam there's some
immediate reaction to the prime
minister's speech here in the hall of
course where the business accepts that
the government is going to also take its
own role in this this rebuilding that's
a big question has already been some
pretty difficult reaction from business
this morning the federation of small
businesses saying the conservatives the
pro party of provinces have walked off
the stage so there'll be some robust
reaction from them to this speech i
think but generally in the whole
conservative party in the cabinet seem
pretty pleased with it
okay
thank you very much dave we'll be back
to you shortly uh with me uh watching
that speech are the former downing
street director of communications in the
theresa may years katy perry and the
conservative mp
matt warman welcome to you both mp for
boston and skegness
i suppose that's red wall not quite i
don't know
anyway what did you take away from that
so what a hugely passionate speech i
mean that is vintage boris there's more
passion for this country there than in
his little finger than there is in all
of keir's prerations over however long
it was at labour party conference last
week so i think what you saw was not
just that passion but you also saw a
genuinely coherent and comprehensive
vision for where he wants to take this
country and now as we come out of the
pandemic is the moment not just to
outline that vision but as he says to
get on with delivering it and so i think
this is a tipping point it's a moment to
get on with it and what you saw was him
outlining it today in a way that we
haven't seen uh yet there's more flesh
on the bones that's great news same old
uh
broken economy of low wages uh
conservatives in power for 10 years do
you think that's something that the
electorate will forgive him for well i
think actually what he's talking about
is the consequences of being in the
european union it's the consequences of
uncontrolled migration that comes from
free movement what he's talking about
today is saying we want an immigration
system that takes the brightest and the
best from around the world but doesn't
discourage the investment in improving
productivity that comes from having an
unlimited supply of labor
okay there's certainly a lot in there
as we said the speech itself he seemed
to be struggling a bit towards the end
it was vintage boris in the sense of the
same old jokes yes he's not that kind of
polished performer but he knows the
audience are going to love it anyway he
peppers it with lots of jokes sometimes
the jokes nobody understands but he
doesn't care he delivers them anyway
it's just typical boris he wants to make
them laugh and smile all the way through
don't forget it's the first time they've
really been able to hear from him since
that general election in 2019 there was
no conference last year this was the
moment to bring everyone together say
let's park pandemic politics let's move
on let's actually do the job that we are
here to do let's do let's go and govern
and tackle the challenges of the day i
call him the the morph and you've got to
be a certain age group to know who morph
is morph of british politics because he
can bend and mold into different ways so
when he was mayor of london he was kind
of pro-immigration
he was pro-immigration and he wanted to
stand up for the city of london today
you've heard him again stand up for the
wealth creators and i think that's a
very important moment i mean a bit of a
conflict there earlier on criticizing
the employers and the wealth creators
and then going back at the end and
saying they were the ones who should
take the credit for the vaccine and all
the rest which uh not sure oxford
university would necessarily be too
delighted with well i i don't think
there is that tension if i'm honest this
is about about encouraging business to
invest in productivity but also working
with for instance academia in that
example it's about remolding a system
that clearly hasn't worked well for
everyone over the last
few years and now we've got an
opportunity as katie says coming out of
the pandemic to really make some of
those fundamental changes that sees the
opportunities of brexit as well now he
talked about stoke pogers because it's
the location of thomas craig's allergy
in a country churchyard seemed to imply
that there wouldn't be houses built uh
in stoke pages but on the other hand uh
saying we're going to build beautiful
homes on brownfield sites so are we
clear where
this house building is going to take
place we're not but we are clear that
boris johnson absolutely wants to put a
house building as a priority of his
government and he's put michael gove in
charge of that leveling up department to
be able to do that the great reformer
there's several times i think the the
the view that i talked about earlier
about the morph of government though is
he's trying to make out that
conservatives haven't really been in
charge of the last few years or indeed
uh the last two decades of the last four
decades and of course he now needs to
move forward and say to people that my
offer of conservatism is very different
from theresa mays and david cameron of
the past he did quite a lot in that
speech to say that the government's in
the past have not had the guts to tackle
the issues of the day and i thought
that's quite telling
no reference of course to his immediate
predecessors at all just just churchill
where and we know he wrote a book about
churchill but
i mean it's clearly going you know he is
optimistic
it was a boosterish speech
did he have enough substance
yes i think it did and i think it cut it
touched on so many different areas where
he is ambitious to make the changes that
people understand they need and even
things like that
realizing that commuting is something
that is really draining and that
leveling up can tackle
both through broadband and through some
of the infrastructure work that he's
talking about as well i think it's
wide-ranging and it's comprehensive but
it's also crucially coherent and what
he's trying to do i think is invoke that
can do spirit that is genuinely
optimistic interesting that he went back
he said we are going to get social care
done
and perhaps gave us a clearer idea of
who's going to pay for that yeah and
he's basically saying that
the government cannot do everything for
you uh in this post-pandemic kind of
position that they are in they've come
out where a country has been paying for
people to stay at home that doesn't
continue we now need to pull the state
back but also invest in the areas that
have been neglected for too long he
talked about an nhs and social care that
actually needed to be much more aligned
rather than how it was set up many moons
ago and who should be paying for that um
but i actually think at times it was
content light but it didn't really
matter because the audience wasn't
necessarily here for this i was waiting
for some more kind of rabbits out of
bags he talked about maths and science
and teachers around three thousand pound
uh investment in putting them in the
right areas i was expecting a few more
announcements like that but he didn't
really need to do so i guess because the
audience really lacked it up anyway and
interesting that you know in the
defining conservatism there the elements
of of walkery there i mean that talk
about beavers and uh uh otters that talk
about violence against women i mean
clearly
this is a prime minister who is not just
thinking about you know conventional
middle age and older conservatives i
mean look i wouldn't think that uh
caring about the countryside or violence
against women and girls is wokery but i
i take the point that you're making he's
someone who has moved with the times i
think that's a really really good thing
but what he was doing when katie talks
about content i think what his role has
to be
is to lead the nation both in spirit and
in practice and what he's trying to
outline is not just that we need more
maths teachers in in deprived areas he's
trying to outline the kind of country
that he wants this country to be and
that's a much more profound vision and i
think it's what you need from a prime
minister it's what we have certainly
haven't had from kierstalma isn't it a
bit confused though i mean one
one breath talking about leveling up and
then the next breath talking about you
know having tall poppies and people who
can succeed he did bounce around a
little actually and um but clearly he
wanted to talk about vaccines more than
once so he started off talking about
vaccines in the nhs and then came back
to talking about the vaccines later on
in the speech i do get the point though
that there is this comparison between an
optimistic view of the future from the
conservative party and what boris
johnson tries to paint out is a
pessimistic view of the future from
kierstarma and that's how he's carried
this conference this week but with a
wave of optimism about the future is
that the best days are yet to come
but at the same time
you know
if if that optimistic vision is
uh not born out does he pay a price or
does he just go on being optimistic the
polls say that he can carry on doing
that for a little bit longer yeah i
think that that content is really
important to make sure that he starts
delivering boris johnson knows from his
time as being london mayor you need a
legacy he's running out of time until
between now and the next election to
build that legacy to go back to the
country and say let me finish what i
started and i know that will be in the
back of his mind about getting on with
the job now
okay we are at the conservative party
conference uh in manchester which in
fact just about over the prime minister
just as you've seen i delivered his
speech a uh short uh speech 45 minutes
uh relatively short for a party leader
packed with jokes and
key phrases as to the optimistic vision
that mr johnson has
for the country he currently leads we'll
have more in a moment